octobre 1970 parmi les 497 personnes
arrêtées et emprisonnées en vertu de la
loi sur les mesures de guerre
des artistes comme pauline julien gérald
godin et gaston miron
mais dans son film les ordres c'est à
des histoires moins connu que michel
gross intéresse on travaillait dans des
vrais lieux
moi j'avais jamais vu ça personnellement
un appartement comme celui d'un qu elle
en tourne même charge revenait pas
sais-tu voyez y avait un saut à 2 sous
la porte
les premières pulsions du flq c'était
bien lutte de classes récemment louise
forestier s'est replongé dans ses
souvenirs avec 50 ans de recul
en regardant le documentaire red sea
mist et rose un devoir de mémoire son
histoire une relation familiale
exceptionnel ça fait du bien à l'homme
cette façon d'expliquer ce mouvement
pour le montrer qu'on pu résister que ce
soit dans octobre de pierre falardeau
montre-moi fait mandat à nos besoins
madame c'est une loi spéciale dans la
télésérie simonne et chartrand
dans son film les rois mongols le picard
souvent raconté la crise d'octobre
il ya eu un peu partout d'ailleurs sur
la terre je sais pas si c'est la
deuxième guerre mondiale qui a provoqué
ça mais il ya eu une espèce de de vent
de liberté
le québec évidemment fait parti de cette
évolution là encore plus parce que les
canadiens français était vraiment
économiquement défavorisés le une espèce
d'éveil extraordinaire des années 60 70
ce qui a été suivie par une espèce de
déception dans les années quatre vingt
une période qui captive aussi sébastien
ricard je trouve vraiment que la crise
d'octobre est un événement qui ressemble
à rien si ce qui a précédé pirinski va
sucer comme une brèche dans l'histoire
du québec
et puis qui s'est refermée je me
souviens des mesures de guerre avec la
série balado pour en finir avec octobre
sébastien ricard et brigitte mks cherche
à comprendre ce qui de cette crise
perdure résonne en nous et nous définit
encore cette souris est encore active
elle ait pu finalement quelque chose qui
appartient maintenant au domaine
vraiment du passé livresque
non il ya encore quelque chose qui est
l'up je pense que ce qui s'y fait pour
moi le grand intérêt de cette date du
jugement
les zapartistes présenteront la lecture
du procès des cinq qui relate le procès
de michel chartrand pierre vallières
charles gagnon robert lemieux et jacques
la rue langlois
ça permet de se rappeler de l'histoire
pour paca se répète puisque si ça se
répète dès on est les arguments pour se
défendre
puis je dirais que les vallières gagnons
chaque train était bon temps
gouvernement prend trop de liberté et
nous prive de nos libertés monde est en
droit de s'y reposer puis c'est une
joute intellectuelle très intéressante
que ce procès là que tout est politique
sans dégager puis séparés lors la
politique c'est je pense pas que c'est
le bon chemin
art.d politique un mélange qui cinquante
ans après la crise d'octobre continuent
de porter à réflexion
ici nabi alexandre charti radio canada
montréal